I think realistically if Elon walks in
the door tomorrow and says guys we did
some simulations and actually it's like
we can get another 5 000 kilograms into
space if we just land it horizontal if
we kind of give up on our ego and land
horizontally at least on Earth
then you know I think they could be
doing that pretty quickly because that's
the thing is uh this ultimate thing has
been to land on Mars and you know other
planets and Mars doesn't have a Runway
doesn't have a you know thick enough
atmosphere to utilize aerodynamic flight
like that so you have to do propulsive
Landing for Mars
um you're going to land on an unprepared
surface you know so it has to be able to
do this at some point the ultimate it
sounds ridiculous and it is but the
ultimate goal of it is to land on Mars
there's not much of an atmosphere to
like to help you with the for the belly
flop to be useful there's only one
percent the atmosphere on Mars as there
is on Earth but you still want to
utilize as much of that atmosphere as
possible so in the upper atmosphere it's
still going to be coming in more or less
uh kind of perpendicular to the
Airstream I guess it's probably more
like you know 60 degrees 70 degrees to
the Airstream like where it's belly
flopping and it's gonna especially do
that on Mars it's going to need to you
know use up as let the a little bit of
atmosphere there is you know you're
coming in at insane velocities and so
even that one percent thin atmosphere is
still going to do a lot of work now on
Mars there's only 38 of Earth's gravity
on Mars so the belly flop maneuver is a
lot it could be a lot more conservative
you could do that at like 5000 feet up
and it just wouldn't matter as much
because there's not as much gravity loss
or gravity drag so you can kind of just
more slowly gently you know you don't
have to do this crazy extravagant like
belly flop you know flip maneuver but it
would still something at some point you
would transition from more or less
perpendicular to the Airstream to you
know and horizontal to Landing
vertically I like how we're having this
old boring conversation about the
differences of landing on Earth versus
on Mars
uh this is surreal that this is actually
a real conversation
but uh this is something that we're
discussing yeah because it has to do
both yeah
in my opinion yes I think we'll pretty
quickly see an evolution of Starship
that's like dedicated versions for
certain tasks sure and at the end of the
day again if if it's if someone runs a
simulation says it's actually more
efficient and it's better just to land
horizontally on a Runway then that's
what's gonna happen you know it it
doesn't matter but they still will
develop you know if the ultimate goal is
to land on Mars then they'll have a
dedicated Mars variant you know which
will likely look different than the
earth variant you know and they'll still
probably be launched on the same booster
you know what I mean so there's Oh you
mean like that particular vehicle will
not be returning back to Earth it'll
need to be modified because uh because
the ultimate is to have one Starship to
goes to Mars lands on Mars and takes off
of Mars lands back on Earth and is
reused again yeah over and over and over
and there's a chance that you you know
you have just a cycler just a you know
if you're if you at the end of the day
you're just really trying to see what is
most feasible what's the most efficient
you literally have a vehicle dedicated
to Mars Mars it's easy to do a single
stage to orbit it's a lot lower gravity
a lot thinner atmosphere you can easily
do a single stage orbit you get into
orbit you park to a dedicated you know
transfer vehicle that goes between Earth
and Mars it only stays in space you
don't have heat shields you don't have
Landing Lakes you don't have all these
things that you need and ideally it's
nuclear powered so it's super efficient
that gets you back to earth once you're
at Earth you Rendezvous again with
another Landing Starship and that
Starship might be horizontal Runway
Starship you know like yeah there's no I
I don't see the and I think ultimately
it'll win out where we don't have a one
size fits all I think that's that's the
flaw of the Space Shuttle really is that
it was trying to do everything and I
ended up kind of doing nothing well but
that's I think what SpaceX has proven I
mean SpaceX already has variants coming
there's already going to be a dedicated
lunar lander for NASA for the Artemis
program there's already going to be a
tanker variant there's already going to
be likely just a pure cargo version
there's likely going to be a human
version we'll likely see evolutions of
this thing happen you know relatively
quickly
and one once it's all working it's only
a matter of weeks before people riding
on it will be complaining about the
speed of the Wi-Fi
as the old like uh Lucy K joke with like
where you're flying on a chair through
the air it's incredible you didn't even
know this existed and now you're
complaining about it oh that's great
exactly